the bob awards are all about honoring
brave bloggers and there are plenty of
regions in the world where it needs
bravery to express yourself bangladeshi
blogger avg troy was murdered for
voicing his opinion the jury honored his
widow's determination to keep his blog
going supported by the internet
community there are hundreds of people
who are actually sending me messages
supporting me I'm and the support they
have shown in Bangladesh after Bridget's
death the statements came out the way
they got United you know it was amazing
it was very encouraging to see that lack
of support is what drives Muhammad tyeb
a Palestinian refugee from Syria he
received the award in the art and media
category having developed a video game
placing the viewer in the shoes of a
Syrian refugee no not a man I am angry
because the international community
ignores us Holly onion we suffer a lot
of problems nobody seems to care she's
love you so it's quite normal to be
angry on my neck dis Tamizh Italian
moonkin internet privacy is the issue
for Mexican hackerspace Ranchero
electronico which one the Bob's award
for privacy and security and for the
first time DW presented the freedom of
speech award this goes to the imprisoned
Saudi bloggers rave Badawi this is the
most important price the boss have ever
awarded right badami it is a great honor
for me to present you with a freedom of
speech award I hope you will soon be
able to hold it in your own hands in
freedom freedom of expression and human
rights on the internet the three jury
award winners certainly contributed to
these goals some of them at a very high
personal cost